à taire leur campement est devenu pour
eux comme une seconde maison
on est basse et le qg des gilets jaunes
de pompey l'on n'est plus ceci que chez
nous on est bien installé pourra pas
bouger maintenant quoi voilà plus de
trois semaines qu'ils sont là tous les
jours trois semaines qu'ils attendent un
geste fort du président de la république
mais la prise de parole des manuels
macron suffira-t-elle pour les
convaincre de laisser tomber le gibier
si on attend ce qu'on a demandé oui on
partira oui ce qu'on a une vie c'est
bientôt noël
on voudrait bien rentrer à la maison
mais si on n'a pas ce qu'on a demandé
c'est sûr qu'on va continuer encore même
on veut quelque chose de concret n'a pas
besoin de parler pendant deux heures il
suffit de dix minutes suffiront
largement bien concret basse et ça va
dans le sens du pouvoir d'achat d'un peu
tout le monde ceux qui travaillent qui
arrive pas à finir les fins de mois
les retraités la france des ronds-points
sera devant sa télé ce soir tout comme
cette france qui chaque samedi soutient
le mouvement
rita est prêt à redescendre dans la rue
même si ce soir
elle espère entendre une annonce qui lui
fera changer d'offre pour moi
personnellement ce serait que qui
rétablissent un petit peu la justice en
fait il ya beaucoup trop d'injustices
moi mon pouvoir d'achat et qui donne
confiance au peuple qu'il leur avenir
sera mieux j'ai envie d croit j'ai envie
qui qui qui fasse quelque chose
l' envie d'y croire comme des millions
de français qui écouteront le président
dès 20h